[Música]
buenas tardes como nos han dicho mi
nombre es iván juanes soy profesor de
griego en el instituto de chamán aquí en
las palmas de gran canarias y aunque no
sea completamente lógico a partir de esa
descripción soy la persona que imparte
el taller de robótica educativa en el
instituto y además la persona que
coordina el proyecto europeo de robótica
erasmus en el centro
la primera pregunta que yo me hago
dentro de la pequeña historia que voy a
contar hoy es
como puede ser que alguien que hace 6
años no sabía la diferencia entre un
voltio y un amperio esté impartiendo un
taller de robótica y la segunda pregunta
para nada relacionada con la primera es
que tiene esto que ver con el hecho de
que las niñas a las chicas quieran
estudiar robótica la cuestión es que en
el año de 2011 llegó una compañera nueva
el instituto cristina naranjo ella
también quería aprender robótica
aprender y enseñar
en aquel momento
me propuso le propuse no me acuerdo
vamos a aprender los dos robóticas y en
los recreos
vamos a enseñar como actividad tras
colar en nuestro tiempo
la cuestión y aquí es donde viene
la primera el primer desarrollo de la
historia es que no tuvimos en ningún
momento ninguna restricción sobre quién
entraba en el taller
no pensamos tienen que entrar los
alumnos con altas capacidades no
pensamos tienen que entrar los alumnos
con dificultades de aprendizaje no
pensamos tienen que entrar alumnos de
sexo masculino y alumnas de sexo
femenino simplemente en las puertas del
taller estaban abiertas pero como pueden
suponer por el título de la charla
empezaron a suceder cosas el caso es que
uno de los proyectos en los que nos
involucramos
fue el proyecto de la plataforma
oceánica de canarias el proyecto plocan
en ese momento nuestro alumnado empezó a
construir submarinos empezamos a
aprender cómo se construían y al
participar en el proyecto íbamos a la
piscina pública que había alquilado
colocaban para el evento con nuestro
alumnado
para probar los submarinos pilotar los
esos submarinos que habíamos estado
haciendo en clase y durante los recreos
y lo primero que pasó es que
había un reparto de papeles simplemente
el alumnado que le gustaba de él
del evento que gustaba de los submarinos
pues como pueden ver tenía una pequeña
inclinación no tiene mayor importancia a
veces hay más chicos a esas más chicas
la cuestión es que seguimos
desarrollando
por ejemplo los mandos robóticos y al
año siguiente también teníamos un buen
equipo
y lo que pasó al año siguiente fue que
todavía había un equipo que ya empieza a
notarse una pequeña pauta no tiene
importancia pueden ser altos bajos
en pequeños grandes eso no tenía
importancia lo que sí cambió todo en mi
forma de ser es una pequeña anécdota en
la historia que me provocó en las
emociones que yo les y sentir
indignación y orgullo orgullo del bueno
de estar orgulloso de porque es la
siguiente que van a ver tiene muchísima
modificación por photoshop para proteger
la imagen pública de los niños
involucrados por supuesto lo que pasó
fue que otro instituto apareció con un
solo profesor y cinco alumnos
aquí tiene la imagen modificada para
proteger la privacidad
claro en ese momento yo elegí sentirme
indignado saben que enfadarse no es
bueno excepto si es una energía positiva
yo no sabía dónde me iba a llevar esa
indignación la verdad es que no pero por
otro lado el otro sentimiento que yo
conseguí tener fue de infinita
satisfacción y de sentirme orgulloso por
las chicas que teníamos en el instituto
no por nada especial sino porque de
repente me di cuenta del contraste y no
era nada bueno ni malo simplemente
nosotros en el taller teníamos a quien
quisiera venir pero eso fue lo que pasó
el caso es que como teníamos los mandos
robóticos al año siguiente
local nos volvió a decir qué tal si
ahora que viene en sus majestades los
reyes el rey y la reina
bien en su alumnado junto con el de
otros institutos a enseñar a sus
majestades cómo funcionan estos
submarinos dentro de su visita a la isla
muy bien
christina tiene espíritu y vamos a ver
qué alumnado está preparado pues ya
supondrán qué es lo que pasó lo que pasó
es que el alumnado preparado
obviamente otra vez eran chicas por la
cuestión que fuese en esta historia
el caso es que avanzando en los
proyectos y cuando christina ya no
estaba en el instituto
tuvimos un proyecto europeo de robótica
y como es lógico es normal un proyecto
europeo de robótica de tecnología le
dijeron al de griego del instituto
tienes que llevar tu completamente
normal ya estamos acostumbrados
en ese proyecto empezaron a suceder una
cadena de acontecimientos de pequeñas
historias bastante peculiares la primera
es que fuimos a la playa de las
alcaravaneras a un espacio de coworking
a una empresa de emprendedores y allí
moix el gerente de un espacio de
emprendedores me dijo oye voy a llevar a
una emprendedora paquistaní a danielle
sharaf mujer cristiana paquistaní y
empresaria
digo esto promete pero allí en la playa
hay una foto que hoy no hay tiempo de
esta emprendedora interactuando con mis
alumnas y aquí es donde viene la segunda
pregunta de esta historia porque muchas
me dijo que te parece sí
buscas a 5 alumnas de su instituto y las
llevamos al evento tecno versión que
después explicar en qué consiste y yo
que debe ser que era un poco chulo le
dije claro pero me vamos a meternos para
ganar
once mil niñas en todo el mundo para
ganar vale bien yo no sé por qué lo dije
porque no soy competitivo pero bueno esa
fue otra pequeña parte de la historia
porque estas niñas al final como algunos
de ustedes ya saben llegaron a la final
europea del evento
al final con esa app sucedieron un
montón de historias que aquí no hay
mucho tiempo de contar la embajada de
eeuu acabó en el instituto conocieron a
otras emprendedoras y al final en toda
esta cadena
acabaron en un hackathon en londres
àngel heart también las captó y el caso
es que yo me veo cogiendo un avión a
birmingham con tres niñas de 17 y 18
años para irnos a catón en londres que
uno de los tres más competidos del mundo
junto con el de silicon valley y el de
singapur y nos presentamos por ahí en un
sitio super competido y lleno de
ingenieros con un montón de proyectos
super interesantes
y las tres niñas del instituto lo que
tenían era una app con un fin social que
habían presentado a un concurso del
instituto claro bueno bueno lo que ya se
pueden suponer que pasó por esto
carambolas que hace que sea una historia
curiosa es que ganamos
ganamos el jaquetón y dentro de la
categoría de una app con un fin social
total ahí ya estas niñas se les
precipitaron los acontecimientos en ese
momento antes les pagaba un acelerador
de empresas están aprendiendo a
programar ya llevar su empresa montando
una empresa ante a la web al final
resulta que salen en la prensa ya
conocen muchos de ustedes la historia la
cuestión es que al final del todo este
año están en primero de carrera ellas
apadrinan a otras niñas y bueno acaban
otra vez invitadas a un evento con sus
majestades pero la historia no es
importante por lo que ha pasado aquí
esta historia no termina aquí aquí es
donde empieza porque que es lo que
sucede que dentro de los proyectos en
los que estábamos involucrados este año
otra vez nos volvemos a meter en el
evento de techno bay son aquel año de
nuevo como muchos de ustedes saben
podría ser que hubiera 20 niñas en toda
canarias involucradas en el evento
pero la historia comienza aquí porque
sucedió otra sorpresa en el instituto
cuando estas propias niñas que ya han
decidido ser mentores y ayudar y otras
personas van al instituto a proponer que
las alumnas vayan al evento de techno
weissohn en un instituto de un barrio
pequeño en una ciudad aquí en medio del
atlántico solo en el instituto al
principio decidieron apuntarse al evento
de tecnova y son 70 niñas
claro eso es por lo que he querido dar
la charla porque la historia empieza
aquí
cuál es la idea
si un profesor de griego simplemente por
las ganas y el tiempo que quiere dedicar
y las ganas de aprender a cinco personas
que pasan por delante en este caso cinco
chicas y gracias a la ayuda de otras
personas como el otra mentora adriana
pueden suceder estas cosas están
maravillosas imagínense y por eso es mi
propuesta de hoy por favor por favor
imagínense lo que sucedería si cada uno
de ustedes que seguro que tienen
muchísima más inteligencia emocional más
preparación técnica y más capacidad
empresarial que yo imagínense lo que
sucedería si cuando cinco niñas cinco
personas que quieren aprender les pasen
por delante
ustedes dedicarán una parte de su tiempo
para conseguir cambiar el mundo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
mira
[Música]